[Music]
on this Tuesday night Donald Trump
arraigned again I think it's going great
the former U.S president's court
appearance and the parade of protesters
and his supporters
frustration for Alberta's fire evacuees
I really want to go back home why
upcoming rainfall isn't expected to
provide relief
Russia's deadly assault on the Ukrainian
president's Hometown as fears renew
about Europe's largest nuclear power
plant
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
history has been made in a Florida Court
former U.S president Donald Trump made
his first court appearance on federal
criminal charges and there was no
shortage of support waiting outside
[Applause]
Trump pleaded not guilty to all 37
counts he's accused of retaining and
hiding classified documents after
leaving the White House and then
blocking government efforts to get them
back
is out of control
Trump remained defiant after leaving
court heading straight to a popular
Cuban restaurant packed with supporters
he posed for pictures and even flashed a
thumbs up
our Jackson prosco is in Miami tonight
outside the courthouse Jackson today's
hearing kicks off what will be a
dramatic judicial process what are
Trump's supporters saying
well me too they're standing by him to
the very end they believe this is a
Witch Hunt against him they believe he
has been unfairly targeted and it's
clear the former president very much
plans to try this case in the court of
public opinion
[Applause]
outside the courthouse Trump's
supporters rallied in his defense keep
fighting for us
they came here from across Florida go
everywhere everywhere he is that I can
go to I will go certain their political
hero is falsely accused of dozens of
federal crimes do you think he should
have just given the documents back when
he was asked to
hear his documents he is the only person
in all the documents that is allowed to
have any of those documents
Trump arrived at the court with his
alleged co-conspirator his aide Walt
NADA who was accused of helping the
former president hide dozens of Highly
classified documents after being
fingerprinted and formally arrested
Trump's lawyer pled not guilty on behalf
of his client to all 37 counts as the
former president sat stone-faced and
Silent special counsel Jack Smith was in
the courtroom but as far as the charges
they are powerful they are damning the
evidence is against them but with
someone as polarizing as Donald Trump
all you need is one juror to say eh he's
my guy and I don't want him going to
prison the indictment is centered around
Trump's willful retention of National
Defense information after he left office
including 31 counts of possessing highly
classified documents outlining U.S
nuclear secrets and foreign military
capabilities all of them were discovered
in unsecured spaces at Trump's Florida
Resort including a bathroom and a
ballroom the documents were found after
Trump ignored a subpoena for their
return he passed he stored them away he
hid them he told people to lie for him
he disseminated them and now he's going
to have to perhaps pay the price for it
the former president has never faced
greater legal liability if convicted on
all counts he faces up to 100 years in
prison
outside the court Trump supporters were
clear they believe Trump will not only
beat the justice system he will win
again this is
[Music]
I'm out of it stronger
there's still no former formal schedule
for a trial at this point one of the
conditions though of Trump's release
today is that he not discussed the
particulars of the case with any of the
potential Witnesses involved and they're
going to be drafting a list of those
potential Witnesses tonight Trump is in
the air headed to his golf course in
Bedminster New Jersey and his first
order of business after his historic day
in court will be a sit down a private
meeting with his top donors as he seeks
to capitalize on today's developments me
too all right Jackson prosco in Miami
thanks Jackson
in Ukraine a Russian missile strike on
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski's
Hometown has killed at least 11 people
the attack happened as the first
independent footage was released showing
Ukrainian troops liberating Villages as
part of kiev's counter-offensive Russian
President Vladimir Putin however claims
Ukraine is paying a heavy price for its
push to retake land Redmond Shannon
reports
exhaustion and despair this time in
kriviri the home city of President
Vladimir zielinski Ukrainian authorities
say those killed by Russian missiles
were inside this apartment building and
in non-military warehouses Vladimir
Putin insists Russia never targets
civilians but says Ukraine is paying a
heavy price on the front lines
he claims a quarter of keys Western
supplied tanks and armored vehicles have
been destroyed since Ukraine's
counter-offensive began
they lost over 160 tanks and over 360
armored vehicles of various types during
this time those numbers have not been
verified
however some of Ukraine's claims of
retaking villages have now been
independently confirmed this footage
from Reuters news agency shows the
abandoned Village of nescusine in
Donetsk region
to the West in hersan region one week on
and both sides continue to blame each
other for the collapse of the kakova dam
this woman collecting drinking water
calls it ecological Warfare of River
from the dam Reservoir levels remain low
the head of Ukraine's State Hydro
company says the water level could even
drop below a critical Level under which
the zaparisian nuclear power plant could
no longer receive cooling water in Kiev
the head of the un's nuclear Watchdog
sounded more concerned about the effects
of the counter-offensive but I'm very
concerned the possibilities of a hit we
had those without any counter offensive
so all the Marshall now that we have all
these combats in the area Rafael Grossi
is on route to the site with a new team
of observers now looking to manage two
threats to the safety of Europe's
largest nuclear power plant Redmond
Shannon Global News London
police in the UK say a 31 year old man
is under arrest in connection with a
crime spree that left multiple people
dead in the English city of Nottingham
today there has been a shocking and
tragic series of events which has led to
the lives of three innocent people being
taken
and left another member of the public in
a critical condition in hospital
s say the attacks happened early this
morning two 19-year-old University
students were found stabbed to death in
Nottingham's City Center three others
were found wounded nearby after a driver
in a stolen van reportedly attempted to
run them over a man in his 50s was also
later found fatally stabbed in a nearby
Street officials believe all three
incidents are linked but no motive has
been determined
turning now to the out-of-control
wildfires raging across this country
with Canada already experiencing its
worst Wildfire season of the 21st
century officials concerns are quickly
shifting West Strong Winds a patchwork
of rainfall and the potential of severe
weather isn't expected to help in the
coming days and as this historic season
drags on Crews on the ground are already
feeling exhausted Heather urich's West
reports
on the fire line near Edson Alberta
crews are working day and night this
right now is the biggest largest threat
in Alberta and they have thrown in the
last few days have thrown every resource
of these fires there's just too much at
stake here the Pembina Wildfire complex
is more than three times the size the
city of Edmonton with a finger of the
fire a little more than a kilometer from
the town of more than eight thousand
residents several days into their second
evacuation of the spring I really want
to go back home I don't want to stay
here anymore longer it's been bad it's a
very different year we've come into the
summer season at quite a deficit with
precipitation and even a normal
precipitation year for summer and in
particular June won't be enough to make
up for the deficit that we're in
environment and climate change Canada
expects less rain than normal this June
not more over the fire zone in the
coming days precipitation will come in
patches some areas will get a lot others
not at all
for the crews fighting the fires near
BC's Tumbler Ridge the weather has been
helpful as a result we do have structure
protection equipment being demobilized
as of this morning in anticipation of
hopefully those evacuation orders and
alerts can be reassessed but on
Vancouver Island less promising news
[Music]
last week the Cameron Bluffs fire east
of Port Alberni forced a critical
Highway on the island closed officials
say it will remain that way for another
week or more Western Canada's worst Fire
season to date with several long months
to go Heather urich's West Global News
the RCMP is investigating more than 100
files related to foreign interference
including three involving MPS interim
commissioner Michael duhammer and Deputy
Commissioner Mark Flynn told a
parliamentary committee the force is
looking into allegations China targeted
conservatives Michael Chong and Aaron
O'Toole as well as new democrat Jenny
Kwan Flynn says the RCMP has been in
contact with election officials about
the allegations which he says mounties
first learned about through the media
we have learned about specific
individuals that were targeted through
the public disclosure not through other
means but through the public disclosure
of specific individuals that have been
targeted and it is those matters that we
reached out to the commissioner of
Canada elections to offer our assistance
if required
the high-ranking officers say there
should be better information sharing
with both MPS and the public
the unprecedented departure of a Justice
on the Supreme Court of Canada is
leading to calls for more transparency
Russell Brown resigned yesterday
following accusations he was involved in
a physical altercation at an Arizona
hotel in January the incident triggered
a complaint to the Canadian judicial
Council but as Taria Israel reports much
of the legal process has remained Under
Wraps
are you gonna call us body cam video
captured a low point for Canada's
highest court police arrived at a hotel
lobby in Arizona last January after this
man called 9-1-1 and he tried getting
around me to the girls and I punched him
he was Supreme Court Justice Russell
Brown five months later the
confrontation has cost him his job it's
the first time a Justice of the Supreme
Court of Canada has retired in the face
of an inquiry into their conduct a group
of friends staying at the hotel met
Brown at the lounge and invited him over
for a drink they alleged he started
harassing the women at the
tablet yes
police alleged Brown tried following the
women to their rooms that's when their
friends stepped in kind of fought him a
little bit he wrote my shirt in the
police report officers found the use of
force appeared reasonable and necessary
no crime was determined no arrests made
Brown was placed on leave in February
after Canada's judicial Council received
a complaint and started investigating
but that was never announced publicly
and only came out after journalists
noticed his absence the council
recommended a public inquiry into
Brown's Behavior but he stepped down
before it could even begin we take those
questions seriously the ethics our
judges in a statement he says the
allegations made against me are false
but I have decided that the common good
is best served by my retirement
Canadians may never get a full
explanation on what happened that night
since the judicial Council plans to keep
its findings secret there's something
opaque right now and I'm not comfortable
with that brown is from Alberta the
prime minister is expected to appoint
someone from the West to replace him
chief justice Richard Wagner is urging
the prime minister to make a decision
before The Supreme Court starts hearing
cases again in the fall Taria israe
Global News Ottawa
the battle against a religious ban in
Quebec coming up the fight to allow
prayer rooms in public schools
foreign
civil liberties and Muslim groups are
fighting a Quebec government ban on
prayer rooms in schools the groups were
in court today asking a judge to suspend
the ban ordered by the education
Minister Mike Armstrong has the details
this public high school in Laval was the
spark the administration had made a room
available over the winter for Muslim
Students to pray prior to that they'd
been doing it in places like staircases
and in the parking lot
that accommodation came under Fire in
April in Quebec's National Assembly a
pot skip Aqua member tabled a motion
that in an officially secular Province
prayer rooms don't belong in public
schools the motion passed unanimously
education Minister two weeks later
issued this directive Banning religious
activity in schools in a tweet
bernardville said he was preserving the
secular character of schools calling
them places of learning not places of
worship this has no place in a country
like Canada the National Council of
Canadian Muslims is now challenging the
directive joined in its efforts by the
Canadian civil liberties Association
they were in a Montreal courtroom
Tuesday asking a judge to suspend the
application of the directive they say
Court challenges should be heard and
ruled on before the ban is applied that
said it's already in effect the prayer
room at this school has been taken away
the groups fighting the bands say
they've heard stories from schools where
children are being told to hide while
they pray one was mocked by a teacher
for praying and another one was
threatened with discipline if they were
seen praying this has become a total
prohibition on prayers in school and we
are here to challenge that now the
directive Builds on Quebec's
controversial secularism law advans
provincial employees and positions of
authority from wearing religious symbols
that includes teachers it does lead to
ironic twists on occasion like at the
high school in Laval it was once a
Catholic school and still has its cross
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
this next story is when nightmares are
made of a woman declared dead and placed
inside a coffin after suffering a
possible stroke woke up during her own
wake
it happened in Ecuador last week the 76
year old woman started knocking on her
coffin five hours into the funeral when
they opened the lid they found out she
was actually alive and breathing heavily
a government investigation is now
underway the woman was taken back to
hospital and is in intensive care
still ahead author Cormac bankarthy a
Titan of American literature dies at 89.
[Music]
emergency relief camps are beginning to
fill up in parts of Northwestern India
as the region braces for its first
Cyclone of the Year officials say the
powerful storm could slam ashore as
early as Thursday neighboring Pakistan
is also working to relocate thousands
from several Coastal communities ahead
of the storm India's meteorological
Department says the Cyclone is already
packing Winds of 180 kilometers per hour
American Pulitzer prize-winning author
Cormac McCarthy has died at the age of
89. a statement from McCarthy's
publisher penguin Random House confirmed
the novelist died of natural causes at
his home in Santa Fe New Mexico the
writer was best known for his vengeful
and violent tales of the American
frontier and post-apocalyptic World
microwlay reports it were it must have
been terrifying for even Oprah to sit
down with Cormac McCarthy he was a
writer's writer a recluse their TV
interview was his first and often when
he spoke his thoughts tended towards the
cerebral like the role the subconscious
plays in our lives somewhere in my head
someone's making up the next thing I'm
going to say which I don't even know
what it is yet he spent years in poverty
and his novels captured hardship
Darkness violence but they were
beautifully written lean unflinching
looks at Humanity's underbelly disguised
as poetry his imagination gave us Anton
chigur the Relentless hit man moving
through No Country for Old Men more
Unstoppable Force than mere man no
backstory no explanation for his
brutality do you have any idea
how crazy you are
you mean the nature of this conversation
I mean the nature of you
while his stories were often adapted for
the screen McCarthy kept a low profile
famously never promoting his novels or
giving public readings his singular
focus on the pros that served as the
heartbeat to his writing he was so
dedicated to his craft he missed the
birth of his first son so he could write
their number one truth
truth is what happened it ain't what
come out of somebody's mouth his first
novels were well received but failed to
sell the romantic Western All the Pretty
Horses let off a string of hits that
included the post-apocalyptic novel the
road you ain't got the two shells maybe
one and now he had shot Maybe
loss suffering Bloodshed and fate all in
one short scene McCarthy was perhaps the
greatest novelist of his generation an
original voice who left it all on the
printed page for better or worse you
just hear once life is brief and have to
spend every day of it doing what
somebody else wants you to do is not the
way to live it
and I don't have any advice for anybody
on how to go about that except if you if
you're really dedicated you can probably
do it Cormac McCarthy was 89.
all 13 Canadian Nordstrom stores are
shutting down for good today in March
the luxury U.S retailer announced it was
pulling out of the Canadian Market
saying it didn't think it would ever be
profitable about 2500 people are losing
their jobs Canada's first Nordstrom
store opened in Calgary in 2014.